good afternoon everyone my name is
Jorden sigani I'm
for engineer and manager on Google
bigquery I've been working on big pay
for about six years I wrote a book on
bigquery which is great if you want to
learn more about how bigquery works or
I've also heard it works really well as
a monitor stand I'll be joined on stage
in a few minutes by Costas Keeley Otis
from from Kabam games one of the biggest
developers of mobile games and also a
big user of bigquery so I'm going to be
showing some queries over a petabyte of
data and it's easy to lose track of what
these numbers mean when they get this
large you know one with 15 zeros or in
binary to to the 50th you know how is
that bigger than a terabyte so to kind
of give a grounding on what a petabyte
means if you put a petabyte on two
floppy disks and you stack them up they
would be three miles high that's higher
than twelve Empire State building's
maybe you've got a mobile phone that has
4G internet and you feel like hey this
is pretty fast if you wanted to download
four petabytes on your phone it would
take 27 years and you better hope you
have a limited data plan the Library of
Congress has every english-language book
ever published they also have audio and
video collections that's still only ten
terabytes so you need a hundred of those
to get to a petabyte and Twitter is is
20 petabytes so the you need 50 times
the the Twitter corpus to equal a
petabyte I don't know about you it's a
little disturbing to me that the Twitter
corpus is larger than the Library of
Congress but maybe I'm just
old-fashioned
so it also turns out that a petabyte
isn't that large anymore a lot of people
have store genomes and do genome
processing in bigquery and just two
micrograms of DNA can store a petabyte
worth of data every day a petabytes
worth of video is uploaded to YouTube
that's a lot of cat videos and you know
maybe you think well a petabytes not
relevant to me if you have a few dozen
servers and they're logging at a pretty
decent clip in a few years you're gonna
have a petabyte as well so what does a
petabyte look like can we switch to the
demo please so we went out and we looked
for a petabyte data set and it turns out
there aren't any public ones and there
aren't even any reasonable ones for sale
so we generated one ourselves so we had
40 virtual machines working for two
weeks solid in order to come up with
with one petabyte so this this is a
retail data set simulating retail sales
so we've got a customers table which has
customer information and we've got about
4 million customers
we've got about 2 million products that
has a products table has has product
information and then the interesting
table here is the sales table 1 trillion
rose and 1.09 petabytes to give an idea
of what this looks like we have the
basically sales ID we have date and
customer information and then we have
individual line items and I kind of want
to show you what this looks like because
there's there's some games that you can
play if you've got a column store like
bigquery does that that make it easy to
sort of generate a fake make it easy to
cheat when you're generating large
amounts of data and I just want to show
that we're not doing this we don't have
a large
padding field that we never we never end
up using and also you can you can take
advantage of column compression by
having like the same the same element
multiple times and actually this this
table compresses extremely poorly
because we have so many unique
floating-point values so I just wanted
to make sure that it was it was clear
that we're not trying to try to pull a
fast one here so I'm gonna run a query
over this table and this query is going
to process 1.09 petabytes now in
bigquery you only pay for processing the
columns that you were that you are
reading in your query so most of the
time you wouldn't actually read all the
columns in a table but I wanted to show
you can do this in a reasonably fast
amount of time so this is doing a select
star and it's doing a filter by by the
the order name so here's a query that
you did you might more like be a little
more likely to run it's computing the
the total sales for a particular
customer by by date and I'm gonna run
this concurrently while this other
petabyte query is running just to show
you that hey you can run multiple very
large queries at once and before these
finish I'm going to switch back to the
to the demo I'm sorry to the the
presentation there we go
I'll come back to those in a second to
show how long how long those those took
I'll also show some more interesting
hopefully faster queries after that so
what is bigquery hopefully haven't
wandered into the wrong the wrong room
and you've heard of bigquery maybe you
heard the Spotify folks talking about it
and how how well it's working for them
but bigquery is a fully managed no ops
data warehouse and when we built a
bigquery we didn't actually realize how
important this no ops part was we just
thought we were building a big data
query engine but you're talking to
customers and in in the way seeing the
way it's used the no ops I think is
really the killer killer feature and
that means you don't need indices you
don't need instances instances you don't
need to worry about replication you
don't need to worry about upgrades and
downtime we we worry about all that
stuff so so you don't have to hopefully
I'll be able to show today that the
bigquery scales to petabytes we have
many customers that that have petabytes
of data hopefully also believe that it's
fast after showing some of these some of
these queries that I'm running it's got
the convenience of sequels so you don't
need to write code in order to interact
with it you can write code if you want
to we have user-defined functions you
can write in JavaScript and it's durable
and highly available and to give an idea
of what the traditional approach to
highly available analytics looks like
this is the the green boxes here are
essentially what you what you get if you
buy an instance from one of our from one
of our competitors and all the rest of
the things around here you have to build
yourselves when you use bigquery we
handle all of that for you I I worry
about replication I worry about whether
the network network is working I worry
about upgrades and my team and
and the the Ops people at Google care
about all this stuff very deeply but for
you what it looks like it's just a big
red button you run your query you upload
your data and it all just it all just
works so what our custom what our
customers say well according to one of
our customers at least bigquery is the
best thing that ever happened to him
and as I was preparing this talk
somebody said to me you know I think
sometimes people exaggerate a little bit
on Twitter and I I thought oh man I
guess we could use a second opinion and
so we've got Costas Polly Otis here
from-from Kabam he's a lead analyst for
Kabam Vancouver on Marvel contest of
Champions he's got more than 15 years of
data warehousing experience so he's seen
how you do it in bigquery you've seen
how you do it elsewhere
hopefully he prefers the big gray
version thanks Jordan for the
introduction I've been a data analyst
and data warehousing person for about 15
years
I learned data warehousing from TD WI
and have taken the courses from Kimball
star schemas were always kind of a big
hack on relational databases working as
data warehouses bigquery has really
enlightened me and changed my life
significantly and we're gonna talk about
how so here's some of the games we have
a Kabam
probably a lot of people in this room
saw the presentation that's that Spotify
put on next door I did too we have a
much different problem at Kabam because
we have a lot of different games that
have very different analytics needs some
we acquire through acquisitions some
we've grown historically from from a
MySQL based game Marvel contest of
Champions was the first large-scale big
game based on our platform to use
bigquery and the data volumes that we've
gotten wouldn't be able to we wouldn't
be able to handle them any other
our existing infrastructure before we
launch contest of Champions worldwide we
have a bunch of servers running our
games so our game is basically a thin
client a dumb client talking to our
servers that do all the processing some
games aren't built like that and they're
very prone to hacks so we're you know we
built it from the server out the right
logs to scry blog aggregator ascribed as
a technology built by Facebook to
aggregate logs and they talk to MongoDB
in the background unfortunately for
people who hate SQL SQL isn't dead which
is why bigquery fills that role for us
[ __ ] is a lot tougher to query than
then traditional SQL databases so all of
our analytics is done from an SQL based
data warehouse at the time we were using
Amazon redshift and this was the system
that worked well for Fast and Furious 6
which is a much smaller scale game than
Marvel contest of Champions we also have
these workers that did our ETL that
transferred the data from s3 to Amazon
redshift and then we consumed redshift
into tableau that worked fantastic for
Fast and Furious 6 but we were drinking
from a firehose when Marvel went
worldwide thanks Play Store for the
featuring but we couldn't handle the
data anymore
the majority of the bottleneck was in
redshift we had to use an SSD based
redshift cluster to get any sort of
performance we continued to upsize that
cluster to the point where was costing
us $100,000 a month we had massive
contention on our ETL we had to change
our sort keys in redshift if anyone's
familiar with redshift you know each
table can only have one sort key we had
to change the sort keys to be convenient
for the ETL which meant that running any
queries really sucked it didn't work as
well redshift and tableau tableau kind
of turns your queries into a cursor
there's a 64 concurrent cursor limit
because our queries were slow we ended
up with a lot of contention and tableau
we ended up having to filter a lot of
data to try to work with redshift at our
peak we were processing 50,000 events a
second at launch and we were processing
a terabyte a day for six weeks we didn't
really have any logging or any reporting
or didn't know what was going on in the
game and as the lead analyst for that
game if my job was really boring cost us
how's our KP eyes looking yep so why
bigquery it took us six days to get
caught up when Google first released
bigquery you could only do small table
the large table joins so it was kind of
more of a traditional solution for star
schemas it looked great but with game
data that's so messy and logs that you
want to piece together it didn't really
work for us so I thought it was a really
nice toy but it wasn't something I
wanted to really work with yet later on
Google introduced the join each and
group each by concept where you could
join large tables together so an
activity like going through a quest has
one log table and getting current seeing
in our game is another table we wouldn't
have been able to join that data
together unless we pre aggregated it to
a small enough level where bigquery
would have liked it so ultimately we
picked bigquery because our tier two
volumes force us to it was kind of
dropped on our laps it's nice that
Spotify was able to do all the pre work
to get bigquery in there we just had no
choice which is great because we don't
have to tell the users we're doing this
we just did it so I've worked on Hadoop
in the past at a previous studio and at
Kabam we also have a data mirror Hadoop
implementation right now where all of
our games log to a central store so
basic things like logins sessions and
money is because that's kind of common
to all games at kadam unfortunately
Hadoop really sucks for what we needed
we didn't have the right size of a
cluster basically and I know bigquery is
Hadoop
I'm not trashing I do also the flavors
of the month and Hadoop seem to change
and another studio I was at you know it
was hive and CDH 0.6 this guy was like
man we need we need to look at shark
they couldn't get to shark fast enough
cuz presto became the flavor of the
month and then Impala and now spark the
flavor of the month keeps changing and
you have to invest a lot of
infrastructure bigquery has updated
their engine and we didn't even know it
happened Jordan's gonna talk to you
about later so I'm not gonna spoil it
for you guys and at my last studio 200
node cluster wasn't big enough and the
one in Kanban was even smaller I had a
server engineer kept me and say can you
only query one week's worth of data and
I'm like well I'm a data analyst I need
to analyze trends over times like please
don't so it made my job really difficult
because I could only look at a very
small x timeframe and in the end with
bigquery you pay for what you use you
have when you first roll out a Hadoop
cluster you're sizing for the future
with bigquery it just kind of grows with
you your costs just grow as you can take
you down your path you don't need to
build access capacity you know the cost
just scale it's it's fantastic
and our cost dropped actually after
going to redshift by about 70% so here's
what our data looks like we've got 205
million rows trillion rows sorry in our
log in our largest table it's
partitioned by day and our entire data
warehouse and bigquery is 567 terabytes
we're approaching a petabyte we're not
quite there we we hope to get there by
in another six months if we get more
featuring so right now we're loading 1.8
billion rows a day and we're only 2
hours behind the the scribe logs that
are in in in our s3 bucket that includes
copying the data over to Google Cloud
storage before we load them into into
bigquery and on February 20th the last
time I gave this presentation we loaded
1.4 terabytes of data
so we're also using the streak tools for
Chrome everybody's using them they're
fantastic a big shout out to whoever
made those and bigquery mate for Chrome
and box is a fantastic tool for
interfacing with people that want to
work with spreadsheets and not other
more sophisticated reporting tools works
great for budget variances and that kind
of stuff and Streak needs to be updated
a little bit on their pricing so cost
you know here's here's an example query
of mine I do some funky some ifs in here
I do some a table or date range which is
unioning a couple days worth of data and
I'm unioning and I'm doing some
filtering as well so this is a real
query that I used to determine the soft
currency earned per energy noticed I'm
not showing you the results if you're
trying to figure out what map to get
soft currency from it took 21 seconds to
process a hundred and fifty one gigs of
data it imparts three billion rows it's
just phenomenal and it cost 75 cents I
could work all day and and not cost a
lot of money
I then said well I never do this but
what if I queried my largest table for
the entire history of the game two
hundred and five trillion rows as I
showed in my previous slide it took
1,400 seconds to execute and it cost $24
no other Hadoop cluster you could roll
out would have that kind of performance
so if you want to save money Google kind
of buries it in their documentation but
you really want to partition your data
by date there's a new solution coming
that's even better that Jordan will talk
about but it's if you don't do that
you're gonna rack up your bill pretty
quick as you're always processing
petabytes of data to get results from
what happened yesterday
never do a select star that can get
really pricey and query what you need we
we don't have any queries that cost over
a dollar
right now and for commonly used data you
know we create daily aggregates so we
have certain tables where we aggregate
on a user day partition and it reduces
our cost significantly because we're
always querying the same things so
annoying caveats that have also been
dealt with apparently you in table date
range you can only have a thousand
tables in the Union so in about two
years we're gonna hit that wall if we
don't upgrade resources exceeded is a
thing that you may see it's only really
happens when you do a sort I've never
hit a problem I couldn't solve either by
building summary tables as an
intermediary to then sort my data or
just not sorting my data and getting it
out it's it's never stood in my way of
doing my job so long as you work around
the little nuances that happened along
the way the last thing to watch out for
is if you're using an ODBC driver or any
other system to connect you have to a
leus all of your your results because
there's a little bit of gotcha in there
where if you don't alias them they
rename the column and on some systems
like tableau it becomes a big problem so
you know we went through our front-end
selection process we looked a tree - Oh
walks tableau click by man looker B IME
and looker and in the game industry
tableau is kind of kings' so we just
went with tableau and interestingly we
went with tableau online so why game
companies love it gives us a nice big
fat pipe - bigquery we don't have to
worry about bringing in tons of data
into our data center it's managed by
them I'm a big fan of the cloud because
of bigquery and because we're on ec2 and
our new game will be on Google compute
engine it gives a self-service bi tablet
tablet support without VPN and it's a
fantastic support network - so here's
some visualizations I've done in tableau
this is our waterfall obfuscated for
obvious reasons this visualization
actually
the entire history of all of our logins
from the start of the game till now and
it's processing trillions of rows as
well Pareto chart the same thing it's
all of our customers in the game again
obvious office gated I apologize so
Pareto charts kind of the 80/20 rule you
know where you pass the intersection it
it works well with executives we also
look at our tutorial funnel this this is
coming out of bigquery and it's a live
connected report and each step of our
tutorial funnel was logged along the way
and for every user that installs our
game we analyze where our drop-offs
occur interestingly they drop off after
they finish the tutorial some other
quick wins this is a consolidation so we
have we advertised the amount of
installs we had in a previous release or
in a CEO press release but this is this
table is effectively think 200 million
rows right now and I can aggregate this
in two minutes
another thing we like to do is create
heat maps for our quest so this was our
Valentine's Day quest in the shape of a
heart
Bieber loves it and our designers use
this almost exclusively to figure out
where users are stumbling to or not
stumbling to make it harder and
hopefully they give us some more money
we also analyze our currency economy our
herbs and flows this is a consolidation
of that 200 trillion row table and every
day table low refresh is an extract and
stores it this point here shows a place
where users are building up currencies
the red line is basically zero so we
hope they spend everything they get so
on that day we ran a promo where you
could get more currency for a little
cheaper
we then introduced an offer to spend
that currency and we start to see that
that velocity starts to wane to the
right which is about the time we can
start introducing a new offer in our
game so with 15 months at Kabam bigquery
was the only tool out there that could
solve our bandwidth issues and loading
the data and getting us caught up and
doing the data analysis we need I've
been able to mind-game data over the
life of our product and that I never
thought was possible in any traditional
data warehouse the days of purging
historical data are now over we can just
mine our data as we need to it's got a
low cost of ownership given that we have
10 analysts right now that are
constantly hitting bigquery the costs
are still quite reasonable for the value
it brings to us we have a positive ROI
on the analysis we use and it's just
worked wonders for us and it doesn't
stand in the way I heat tools that
produce limitations for me if there's no
limitations at all except for that order
by issue you know ultimately it lets me
focus on the data so I mean it was ready
for us we just didn't know it you know
it's probably gonna be ready for you too
and that's it I'll turn this back over
to Jordan
thanks Kostas it's always fun to see
people that are actually using things
that you build and in interesting ways
that you hadn't thought of that's cool
so how did we get here
Google's first product was was Google
search and Google search is a big data
problem so Google has been working on
big data problems for a long time and
produced this list this wonderful list
of really cool really cool things the
one we're talking about today is is
Dremel and Dremel was the the precursor
of bigquery or the internal name of
bigquery and Dremel was created in 2006
when an engineer named Andre Gubarev got
tired of waiting for his map mapreduces
to finish and while he was waiting for
mapreduces to finish he decided to move
all of his logs into a new columnar
storage format that he that he started
building and built a sequel engine on
top of it and pretty soon he had a an
intern and a couple more people started
working on it and people at Google
started to really like it fast forward
10 years Dremel is mission-critical
absolutely mission-critical at Google
Google is a data-driven company and
without Dremel Google can't get the data
that it needs understand the data that
it needs to make its business decisions
from Interview hiring low interview load
on on engineers to hardware ops planning
capacity to code stats it's used by
virtually everyone at Google across
across job function and the the amounts
of data that are processed are pretty
staggering Dremel is bigquery it's the
same team you know internally we call a
dremel externally we call it bigquery
it's the same codebase we have an
internal copy of the Dremel the trees
but it's the
it's the same thing big query was
launched the general availability in
2012 and so this slide shows the rate of
change in bigquery the yellow lines are
the number of code changes that have
gone in over the years as you can see
those those numbers have been increasing
as have the the number of features that
we've been releasing so what have we
been up to lately
well bigquery we spent the last say year
improving the underlying infrastructure
we wanted to make queries just work
bigger queries just work things that
were not the way people do them
internally just work and the nice thing
is that to our customers they didn't
notice anything changed there was no
downtime they didn't have to do upgrades
things just got better and so some of
these I'll talk about are pretty
fundamental to how how Dremel works so
in the Dremel paper and in virtually
every bigquery talk that's been given
there's a slide like this and talks
about how queries come in at the at the
root the root level of this of this
serving treat they get broken up they
get passed down to the shards shards
read the data they filter the data they
pre they partially aggregate the data
and then the aggregations flow back up
the tree this works really amazingly
great it lasted us pretending 10 years
but for complex queries things like
joins things like group bys that have
have multiple different keys it doesn't
it doesn't work quite as well so we
build Dremel X which instead of a static
tree it builds it a dynamic tree based
on your query so if your query has
multiple pieces multiple stages multiple
joins each one of those stages is going
to be a separate level in the tree we
don't have to do multiple passes up and
down the tree we can basically just pass
data from one from one portion to the
other Dremel X has been has been in
production since since late 2015 people
didn't notice except queries that used
to not not work now just work
queries that were complex now run
several times faster
we've also reinvented our column storage
engine so the in the Dremel paper we
talk about column i/o and I'll give it a
little bit of rundown on on how that
works here call them call owners stores
they they store each data in a separate
stream we're sorry each column in a
separate stream and they compress the
data so this is these these two columns
used in this query we then decompress
the data and then apply apply a filter
relatively relatively straightforward so
capacitor which is our new storage
engine changes it's around slightly we
still have the data stored compressed
still still call in column format but
instead of decompressing the data we
just compressed the thing that we're
looking for and then we match it and
then emit emit the thing that the things
that match and this seems relatively
straightforward and seem as priciple as
they go that's you know of course but it
actually means you have to rewrite the
the query engine the query execution
engine as well to be able to understand
how to operate over compress data this
has had massive performance improvements
on average queries got twice as fast
from but for many types of queries
especially things that do highly
selective filters they're much faster
ten to a thousand times faster and if
you're concerned with veer with high CPU
billing this capacitor uses much less
CPU so your billing tears will also be
lower we've added a bunch more features
as well the we've made it so you don't
you shouldn't need be the each keyword
which Costas Costas mentioned now they
should with with our dynamic query
planning we should be able to just
figure out how to how to run your query
how to size your query which means more
queries will will just work we've
changed the ingestion mechanism to now
we adjust data using Dremel itself
behind behind the scenes and which ends
up being five times faster it's also
allowed to be more flex
we've added the avro storage format
which itself is another 10 times faster
so getting data into bigquery has gotten
much easier and we've added consistent
scheduling we never used to talk about
how much how many workers were using
where your queries could use you get
2,000 workers in in bigquery which is
sort of on the best on a best effort
basis but you can use that to do you
know one giant query or you can use it
to do mm smaller queries but if someone
else is running giant queries it
shouldn't affect your ability to to to
process data so announcing today like so
so these are just some internal things
that have been rolled out over the last
few months but we're also have some some
cool stuff that that were first just
just gonna be talking about today so
storage pricing is very simple it's two
cents per per gigabyte no matter how
much you have but chances are you have
you know some of that data it's
historical data that maybe you use for
quarterly report reuse infrequently you
want to keep it around so that you can
query it when you need it some of your
data is more recent so we're lowering
the price of the historical data
anything over the older than 90 days by
50% this means
this means all of your data all of your
old data either gets 50% cheaper or you
can store or twice as much of it for the
same price this change will be effective
May 1st so it actually you know the
timeline has already started in February
first for historical data and there's
also no change in the query performance
the durability of that data or
availability of the data it works just
like normal we just charge you less for
it we're also announcing table
partitioning today Costas talked about
using table date range which was kind of
a hack and it meant that you have to
manage multiple tables and table date
range was slow not a lot of great things
to say about table date range now
basically you just load data to your
table and we put in a different
partition every day and when you want to
query it you just filter by the the days
that you care about and we will only
bill you for scanning scanning the data
that's in those partitions and the
queries will run faster because we only
have to scan those partitions so to give
a little bit of idea of how that works
kalla in a columnar store we charge you
for the for the columns that you your
query is scanning so let's say you're
just using c1 and c3 we just charge you
for the size of those columns now with
partitioning you can slice it again
again horizontally by day so you end up
getting billed for much less than you
would otherwise
so daily partitions which is only early
access release we're rolling it out to
some select customers first but should
be coming very very soon for wider
availability
I want to mention one more thing is that
you can go back and change individual
partitions after they have been after
they've been created in case you in case
you double the just data or you need you
need to fix something in an older in an
older partition you can just address
those as as individual tables I
mentioned that I mentioned that you get
2,000 workers by default but maybe you
need more than that
and if you need more you can you can
purchase more and once one interesting
caught us ill to that is that if you're
using a lot of bigquery if you're
running a lot of big queries and it's
slowing down because because you don't
have enough don't have enough concurrent
workers we will actually give you more
automatically and today we're also
talking about public datasets and if you
go to the bigquery UI you'll actually be
able to be able to see these datasets
which are high quality public datasets
hosted by some of the folks mentioned
mentioned on here data.gov looker hacker
news gdelt
and you know we provide the hosting and
we also make it free to query those you
can free to query essentially anything
in bigquery for up to one terabyte per
month so anybody who wants to can can
play around with these these datasets
for to scan up to a terabyte and if you
have or you know of datasets that you'd
like us to include please please let us
know okay so you guys probably want to
see how how we do on querying wearing a
petabyte of data would you mind
switching back to the demo please there
we go
okay so this this query process 1.09
petabytes in two hundred and forty five
seconds that's
that's that's 4 terabytes a second in
case it doesn't otherwise seem seem fast
this other query we did took took a
little bit longer took 429 seconds but
it was actually doing doing more but in
general you may not care about
processing all ten years worth of data
you may want to use partitioning which I
was showing before so let's let's take a
look at at at filtering this by picture
partition let's query just one one month
of data you can see that we've added the
partition load time pseudo column here
to find to find only the data between
january 1st january 4th and and february
4th so that took 14 seconds for for one
month worth of data and just just for
fun let's let's try you know just
looking at one one day worth of data and
let's see how long how long this takes
that was 3.2 seconds requiring a
petabyte table it's pretty pretty cool
to me
now what we didn't actually scan the
whole petabyte table so maybe you think
that's that's that's cheating but on the
other hand you could have done any any
partition you wanted of that whole
petabyte and we also only bill you for
scanning ten gigabytes so we're making
it actually affordable to to query over
over these these size tables as well as
making it possible and you may think
well these the queries we just ran are
pretty simple they're they're not all
that you know they're just scan filter
aggregates what about something
interesting like so this this query does
a regular expression it takes an entire
month of data it does a regular
expression over the product keys it
flattens it flattens out those line
items and then it doesn't join against
against the products products table to
get product names and then we use a
window function to compute a running
average over the last seven days so this
is 21 seconds to do a join query and
window functions and over over a an
entire month thank you and can we switch
back to the slides please
okay so what have we what are we talked
about today so we talked about capacitor
which makes your queries faster we
talked about Poseidon which makes it
faster to get into bigquery we've talked
about Dremel X which makes complex
grades faster we talked about dynamic
execution which makes it easier to write
your queries and actually it also makes
your queries faster we've also announced
new features table partitioning Avro
import support I actually didn't mention
automatic schema inference but we did
also launch that today so your imports
and and your federated queries you don't
actually need to specify the schema we
announced the long term storage pricing
decrease bigquery slots and the
availability of public data sets thank
you very much
you